committee the tendencies are being
recorded on
on blue i'm counselor david charm and
i'm chairing the
licensing panel and we have council
thomas and booked as members of
we only have one item on the agenda
which is the
fair addition to the premises lies
the box and hounds woods then road
flexton
and uh do we have the applicant or their
representative
good evening jeff my name is george
domino and i act
on behalf of the app
hello
i think it's gone off again
we can still hear you but the chair is
going to speak he'll bring you back
all right okay i thought it had gone off
i'm sorry
counselor german you're muted man
right we got the applicant here
hello chair my name is george dominio
i'm the solicitor
for the applicant also also on the call
you'll have andrew jameson
who is here on the behalf of the
applicant can we say that
you just broke up andrew jameson
andrew j thank you
and there's
okay um who do we have from
environmental health we have mr
bellfield
and mr sullivan yes i'm here i don't
know if you can hear me but
say i'm here peter bellfield
environmental health officer from
regulatory services chocolate council
right okay thank you um and we have the
resident here
um right just gonna run through the
proceedings and then we'll start the
meeting
so the first thing i'll do is ask the
licensing officer to outline the
application
i will then ask the applicant or their
representative to address the
subcommittee and call any witnesses
the applicant and each of their
witnesses may then be questioned by
members of the subcommittee
officers and members of the public
and the party making representations who
would be referred to as the
and their representatives will then give
an opportunity will then have an
opportunity to address the subcommittee
and call any
witnesses the representation any of
their witnesses may then be questioned
by members of the subcommittee
officers and any other party making
representations
so if there's more than one
representative they'll be called in
in the following order so in this case
environmental health
and members of the public
after this i will request all parties
involved to summarise
the representative or representatives
will be given
two minutes to summarize followed by
the applicant who will also be given two
minutes to summarise
the subcommittee will then consider
their decision
and then i will announce the
determination of the application
and the reasons for the determination
which will also be confirmed within five
days
so to do that in this case we go into
what you call a breakout room
on on zoom so
do we have the licensing officer
yes chair oh hello miss boyle
outline the application please
thank you chair members of the
subcommittee
and a premises license is required in
respect of
any premises where it is intended to
conduct one or more of the four
licenseable activities these being
sale of alcohol supply of alcohol in
respect of a club
regulated entertainment and or the
provision of late night refreshment
and this application was submitted by
flint bishop on behalf of
star pubs and bars limited in respect of
the fox and hounds hotel which is
situated
at 201 woods and road in flixton
the applicant has applied for a major
variation to the current premises
license as follows
firstly to change the name of the
premises as shown on the premises
license to the fox
pub and kitchen secondly to extend the
license
area to incorporate the whole of the
side car part which is to be converted
into an external seating area
to include an external bar servery
thirdly to add non-standard timings for
all the current licensable activities to
read
from the end of committed hours new
year's eve until 1am
on new year's day and in respective
opening hours
from the end of comic hours on new
year's eve until 1 45 a.m
on new year's day finally to remove
existing annex
3 condition 1 which states no person
under the age of 16
will be permitted on the premises or
part of the premises
after 2100 hours and to replace it with
the following condition
children under the age of 16 must be
accompanied by an adult
at all times and must be off the
premises by 2 200 hours
unless on new year's eve when they will
be permitted to remain accompanied
on the premises until close
officers believe the application has
been properly made and all procedures
correctly followed
the application including amended
operating scheduler and plan has been
attached as appendix a and
b paragraph photograph story of the blue
notes
in place and a copy of the newspaper
advert are attached as appendix c
during the consultation a representation
was received from mr peter bellfield
trafford environmental health officer in
relation to the licensing objective the
prevention of public nuisance
and that representation is attached to
appendix f
the representation was also received
from a local resident on the same
grounds
and that representation is attached at
appendix g
greater manchester police are also also
made a representation during the
consultation but they agreed with the
applicant
a set of conditions relating to the use
of cctv
which satisfied their concerns and those
conditions are detailed in the report at
paragraph 3.2
supplement is invited to consider the
application and the representations of
the applicant
and the representation decide either to
approve the application and to modify
the conditions of the license
or to reject the application in whole or
in part
thank you chair thank you mr boyle
um does anybody have any questions for
the licensing officer
no jen i'm from the napkin thank you
okay in that case i will turn to the
applicant
applicant's representative would you
like to
speak to the application please mr
donald
thank you chair well good evening
everybody i hope you're all
keeping well as i said my name is george
dominio and i actually
have been star pubs and bars limited now
by way of background
star pubs and bars limited is a
subsidiary of heineken
who are the third largest brewery i
believe in the world
i have approximately two and a half
thousand licensed premises in their
estate across
england wales and scotland as i've
already alluded to
i have andrew jameson on the call with
me who is the business development
manager for the fox
and covers around 35 premises in and
around this area
also on the call with me is the dps paul
senior and his joint tenant david
thornell
there is a tenancy agreement in place
between heineken and both paul and david
who work closely together within
partnership to make the premises
successful
and assets to the local community
now i don't know whether you're aware of
the premises counsellors but it was
subject to
an extensive refurbishment in may 2019
and it cost my client over a quarter
million pounds
the works carried out transformed the
fox into how it is today
which is a real community pool offering
a great quality selection
an extensive range of food and drink
cater for
all ages hence the request to change the
name of the premises
i share the license to the fox pub and
kitchen
now to provide you with a bit of
background both paul and david's
involvement with the premises
they took on the running of fox around
april 2018 with paul becoming the
in order for them to take the premises
on councillors they needed to submit a
comprehensive and substantial business
plan
which has to be approved by their
accountants and be in line with their
investment forecasts i can assure you
counters that planet can
do not hand over the running of any of
their assets such as a fox to just
anybody
it does not work like that they're the
more counselors since david and paul
took over the
running of fox now over three years ago
we've not been made aware of any issues
with the running of the premises
nor non-compliance with the premise
license which i submit
is an important consideration today when
determining the variation
david and paul also operate what they've
also operated the broad oak
ashen on the line since the start this
year and the goose on bloom street in
manchester since april 2018
they have invested approximately 80 000
pounds into the fox since they took over
running it they've created a real
community asset
now if i turn to the application itself
councillors and you've heard from uh joe
what the
what the application what we are
applying for the main points of
contention from the parties who are
objecting which are each other or
residents
are around the proposal for the side car
park being converted into internal
seating area
and the installation of an external bar
servery
area now in terms of the area being used
as an external seating area
then due to the current government
relaxations with the impact covered and
under the business of planning at 2020
the premises are already permitted to
use this area
and any external area on their landing
consumption area and this reaction is
likely to remain in place until the end
of september
2022 or it's at all times they cannot
create noise nuisance that's not changed
the premise is kind of creating noises
at any time
you will also know cancers from my
correspondence with peter bellfield
which can be found in your
agenda that we have agreed a condition
stipulating that this new external
area shall not be used by customers
after the 9 pm
you will also note from my
correspondence with peter that i am
aware that there is a gate between the
already existing frontier garden
and this new external area which will be
closed when the area is not in use
having discussed the points raised by
the two parties objective
in my client we will be happy to attach
the following additional conditions to
the
license these are firstly staff shall
monitor
customers in the external area on a
regular basis
and ensure customers do not cause a
nuisance
there's also the condition which is
requested by peter on page 50 of your
agenda in relation to the bifold laws it
starts with
or emergency egress we'd be happy to
accept that condition
and the third condition is the notices
shall be prominently displayed at all
public texas
and in the external area requesting
customers to respect the needs of local
residents
and to leave the premises and area
quietly this would replace existing
condition 4 onto annex 2.
and furthermore councillors you will be
aware from page 27 of your agenda
the existing licensing plans shows the
external customer areas to the front
and to the other side which have been in
use for a number of years
which paul and david have operated
completely fine without
any issues so i have full confidence
that they will operate the other side
external area exactly the same
in terms of the proposal for an outside
bar survey we are seeking this
in order to take the pressure off the
main bottle right inside the premises of
heat trading times
to facilitate social distancing and to
create a better customer
experience i'm sure we can all agree
councillors that pubs need
to evolve and require ongoing investment
to ensure they keep pace with changing
consumer needs
and to stay relevant to the community it
serves
furthermore councillors as i've said
with the agreed condition of the
external area to not be used
again this would also mean that the
external bar survey were not used at
this time
the 9 pm i submit is both sensible and
considered
which is accessible sorry considered
measure which was proposed by peter
belfield and agreed by
my client now
sorry i just heard somebody else on the
phone i'll carry on
now we have the two representations
against our application
if i deal with the representation from
the resident firstly we fully appreciate
that there is some
anxiety in relation to any application
the massive it counts as
variation is a considered patient and as
i've already alluded to
both paul and david have operated the
premises and the other external areas
for every three years now without any
complaints
or non-compromise of the license so i
have full confidence that the new
external area will not cause any issues
we also have the representation from
peter and there are a few points i would
like to
raise in response to this the majority
if not all of peter's objection is
purely speculative
throughout his objection he states the
proposal will cause
the potential for nuisance and so on and
at this point counsellors i would like
to draw your attention to paragraphs
9.43 of the section 182 guidance which
states that the authority's
determination should be evidence-based
justified as being appropriate for the
promotion of the licensing objective and
proportionate
to what it is intended to achieve peter
goes on to state in his representation
that the introduction outside bar
will bring the potential intensification
of use of the outside area and potential
increase of noise
now i disagree with this statement
encounters and i don't understand why
the outside area has been abused any
more often
with it having a part consumption will
be permitted in the external area
and able to be offered in any event so
the inclusion of a bar survey
for an area that can only be used until
9 pm
i summit is not going to cause an issue
and undermine a license objectives
and as a previously mentioned casters
it's not like the outside bar is going
to be used in november
but just on the odd occasion when the
weather is to allow that flexibility
he further states that the proposed bar
survey is likely to be frequently busy
with potentially noisy customer cues
that could be troublesome for the
residents in close proximity
again counsellors this is purely
speculative there is no evidence of this
as i've already said to councillors we
have agreed a condition for the external
areas not used after 9pm
we have proposed that fashion regularly
monitor customers in the external
area to ensure they're not causing a
nuisance both paul and david are
aware that there are residents who live
directly opposite to
the rear and to the side of the premises
who can be disturbed by noise from the
premises
paul and david are responsible operators
given the history of operating the
premises over the last three years
without
any issues i had every confidence that
they would not allow this to happen
i can also advise you counsellors that a
member of staff will be doing a general
walk around in this
area and after at all around a they will
be informing customers that they must
either move to the other external
areas or inside by 9 pm furthermore
councillors the premises will erect
signs
advising customers or the operating
times and restrictions of new external
area which i know is another one of
peter's requests
now the external area will predominantly
be used as a beer garden as
most of them normally are it will be
used for customers to enjoy their food
and drink on those days
the weather permits until nine pm
peter also includes some decibel
readings carried out by a resident
operating the noise monitoring and
recording equipment on just one date
that being served may this year there is
no evidence provided by peter of the
decimal levels of the ambient noise
level
and also the noise level from the houses
next door their gardens or from the
highway
i would describe the decimal level
readings provided as still chapter
i submit counsel that the if all the
proposals address
the initial concern the agreement of the
conditions the address
the points have been raised and show
that there are sufficient controls in
place
to ensure that an illuminations can be
caused however
should the residents experience any
noise nuisance from the premise in the
future
then i would have seen it either contact
peter and his colleagues in
environmental health their complaints
or alternatively director paul and david
at the premises and
i'd like to think we can resolve these
in a straightforward manner should they
arise but
um we will both david and paul they are
responsible and conscientious operators
and that is why heineken brought them on
order the fox they know what they're
doing
they have already created a premises for
local communities to enjoy
with the correct measures in place and
without causing any issues
and should any premise license
conditions be breached it is a criminal
offence which carries an unlimited fine
now given the information i've provided
i see no issues the presumption of grant
it is possible
as there is provision within the
legislation for the local residents
or the authorities to issue a review of
the license
or there is other enforcement actions
available should concerns arise in the
future
at which i expect we will be given a
short drift the premises with our
proposals
it should be allowed to continue to
flourish as a local pub
and an invaluable asset to the community
and we should be doing everything we can
to support the right premises and the
right operators after these
unprecedented times
as at the same time promoting the
license objectives
all these reasons counselors i would ask
you to grant the application
as it is before you today thank you
okay thank you sorry hello
just hang on a minute i'll bring you in
in a minute um
uh yeah so uh thank you for that
can you just clarify did you you said
that you but you've agreed to the
condition about the bifold doors
yes chair young page i think it's page
50
in your it's it's a peter's
representation
i think you've got appendix is it
appendix f
but i i haven't got an appendix i've
just got page numbers
but it's on uh let me find it
actually sorry page page 48
yep and it starts with except for
emergency egress
right so you've you've agreed to that so
the the only condition that he's
suggesting
at issue currently is the um to do with
the
yeah the serving of alcohol and
associated activities in the
outside area correct yeah
right okay i just wanted to clarify that
so you've been you've been operating
you've had customers in the outside area
since um lockdown the lockdown was
released at
easter is that correct i believe they
had they used the area and
david and paul are on the court probably
best to answer this one
but i believe they used the area in
question last year when they were
allowed to um and and they've used the
area
this year obviously when they're
permitted but i don't know whether david
paul um pay the actual months but
yeah that's how we've been using it
that's correct we've used it since
june july last year sorry and we've used
it again since april this year when we
could trade
um outside when the first restrictions
were lifted
right so it's just just for seated
drinkers and and obviously we take those
under the
current restrictions yeah just uh seated
um eating and drinking right okay
how many tables of the the area
under question of the new with the car
park area the extension not the beer gun
how many how many
well okay all of it then how many tables
are actually used
given the cobia restriction 25
so 25 are used maximum
yeah that's in the entire area including
the um existing
uh section in front of the restaurant
okay and have you had any complaints
from the residents or have you been made
aware of any
complaints from this has not been made
we've not been made aware of any
complaints other than um
one resident who contacted you directly
well um we're going to be made aware we
made aware on a visit with mr beldfield
and uh two of his colleagues that there
was a complaint last year but
that was never made never made aware to
us
and i believe the complaint they
couldn't get hold of the complaints at
that time
and we've not had any complaints direct
to us
apart from when the um planning license
applications went
into yourselves right well
i mean all right well we can ask mr
bellfield so
the only i mean obviously he wrote to
the email of the 12th of may outlining
his concerns
and and measures he felt needed to get
to get an agreement so you've agreed to
the time limit on the outside area
you've agreed to the bifold doors being
closed
when there's music playing inside
just i mean i just i suppose this is
probably a biggie from your point of
view but can you can you explain
why um you're against the
not having the bar the sale of alcohol
there and any associated activities in
in that area chair if if i may take
the lead on that um in terms of in terms
of the outside bar
i i don't see as i've said in my
submission i don't see how the inclusion
of an outside bar
is going to intensify an area where
we could have customers sitting out
there there's no evidence
at present to say that the outside bar
has caused
issues uh we have agreed like i said to
use the outside area until nine o'clock
which i think is a sensible and
reasonable
time in terms of the associated
activities
do you me can i ask you to
and i think customers congregating in
groups which they could well do around
the bar
but i think in terms of in terms of
music and and i know from
speaking with david but um
the beer gun is predominantly going to
be as i've said in my submission by
customers
seated um eating and drinking that
they're not
planning to have a barbecue out there
they're not planning to show
um i've ever have a big screen
um it is to be used as a given the
concept of the premises
there is quite a substantial food
offering it is kind of an extension of
of the dining room effectively um that's
what that space is going to be used
and as i've said in terms of the the cue
any potential cues at the
boss survey there's there's no no
there's no evidence been submitted
in an issue and furthermore as i've said
all the david had been there three years
where staff from star perspective
license holder they're not aware of any
issues
bss solicitors aren't aware of any
issues with their running so
i feel like i've got full confidence in
paul and david that they'll manage the
outside area as they have done
the internal pub and also from the other
outside areas
right it also mr bellfield suggested
to you didn't make it a condition but um
the the soundproofing of the
fencing where the where the neighbours
are at the back
and uh and also what should we call it
the red line on the plan where he said
that he felt that there shouldn't be any
customer activity beyond that point
would you would you just like
he's not asking for it at this stage to
be a condition but would you just like
to comment on
that yes certainly no thank you in terms
of the barrier
my view was that was more of a planning
kind of matter and i know there is a
current planning application
going through um at the minute so i i
felt it was more kind of
planning remit more more than nice
at the end of the day paul and david
uh they want the local residents to to
come and enjoy
off they don't want to be disturbed um
so they they will work
with whatever the outcome of the
licensing decision is or work with
whatever the planning decision is um
whatever those requests are but in terms
of the barrier
it i've just thought it may be something
more kind of planning
more into planning than the actual
licensing
it gives you a second point chair uh
where the red line uh i know but
obviously i know past the red line is
the actual proposed external bar survey
so that that's why we can't agree to
that red line because
we're still proposing for that external
battery and sits you on that
location okay
thank you councillor thomas you have a
question
yeah thank you uh mr dominio
um just just around the outdoor seating
area
uh on page 49 um one of the
um constraints is that it shall not be
used for the following activities
at any time if we leave behind the
server or coin drinks
uh what objections do you have about the
erection of a marquee
covering the seating area congregations
or standing groups customers
screening of tv films or sport and the
provision of live or recorded musical
entertainment
if it's only a beer gun why would you
object to
to that or is it just a sale of
alcoholic drinks part of that
because obviously if you're in erecting
coverings
then we are looking at use in
the winter months
yeah i i
um i suppose
if you if you determine that you put out
a condition on the license
then um that that's a that's a licensed
condition
to me that's more akin to a planning
matter and i'm not an expert in planning
but i know that
you don't need planning permission to
direct a temporary structure such as a
marquee for 28 days
and it's more sorry sorry to interrupt
uh
it's more about you said the exclusive
uses for a beer garden
to have the ability to or
to reject a condition on the on the
license application
around the screen of tv films
sport live or recruiting recorded
musical entertainment
it sounds to me that it's going to be a
little bit more than a
uh just a beer garden it's going to be
somewhere where you would perhaps put
entertainment on
which is different again
no i i i hate your point councillor um
and if i may uh because this is
obviously more difficult
being done remotely um i am just i'm in
a whatsapp group
at the minute with uh with the client
i've just messaged in the whatsapp group
to see what their response is
and they've said look that there's no
plans for entertainment there's no plans
for tvs
music so if if you were
minded to a patented condition i suppose
it could say
the outdoor seating area position from a
car park to western building
it should not be fun activities and it
would be
where we start as you said counselor
they're just get rid of the sale of our
college drinks
and i suppose that would be um to be
any time congregation standing any
screening any screenings of
tv films or sport and the provision of
live or recorded musical entertainment
i don't know i don't know i'm not sure
about the congregation of standing
groups
i i fully appreciate the proposal with
it but it would
i don't foresee that in the case um
and like i said it is mainly for big one
for consuming
and dining um so with that aspect
they would all be seated in any event so
yes if if you remove the sell apple and
drinks and look pretty were that
condition um
then it's something that a client would
accept
okay okay a preacher for clarity
for clarity yeah no i appreciate that
for clarity although it's he's not in my
ward i live very close and
close to the fox and hounds um and i've
seen many incarnations of it over
the many years i've lived in the area so
i'm just asking for clarity that's all
i'm not i'm not minded either way at the
moment
i'm quite happy to listen to argument no
no but i hope that assists anyway
counselor thank you thank you counselor
thomas counselor
do you have any questions uh thank you
yeah
uh if i could just first of all you know
the notices that would put
is that the only notice that was put up
on the
shows on the window within the papers or
was there anything a little bit further
along
and that the passing public could have
seen
i understand they were the notices that
that was well that was the notice that
was displayed in order the next put in
the newspaper
which is in compliance with the
regulations
all right was that okay from an
officer's point of view
well they already said it was so right
okay
uh the other thing was the you know in
terms of the uh
uh location the beer gun any particular
reason why it wasn't put on the other
side
as opposed to where it's actually nearer
to the residential area
so certainly a counselor if you turn
to page oh
where is it now 20
25 so you're going to piece 25 of your
agenda
on page 27 and you will see
that there is already in existence a
beer garden
do the other side and there is an area
to the front
now that big on as i've said is there
are residents
located around that area as well but but
we're not aware of any
issues with the use of that so this
extension of the car part is to the
other side of the side that's available
yeah no it just seemed like i mean i
think there's only one property as far
as i could see on the other side where
the existing beer garden is
uh but
uh this is the place this is the
location you wanted it so
uh can i just ask in in terms of the
the noise requirement to the the barrier
is is that
was was that meant to be just a vertical
barrier
or uh any
what type is it supposed to be that
you've been acquired
i gather it's cladding put onto the
already thin wooden fence
sort of a cladding that's what i i
understand i mean the environmental
health office will help us with that i
think
i want me to uh just confirm what the
barrier i had in mind was
yeah um so an acoustic
barrier um needs to be
um substantial and dense
enough really made of strong
dense materials to act as an acoustic
barrier
and the minimum um mass
should be 10 kilograms per meter squared
and the barrier must not have any
perforations or gaps to allow sound
through
um and um the the height of the barrier
really
uh is dependent on the effectiveness of
it
um so really there's a minimum um it
should be
a couple of meters high um so
um it's it's possible to install a
barrier but
um if it's not made of the right
materials and it's not
sufficient of sufficient mass it might
not have acoustic properties
so it needs to be something that is uh
bought from a specialist really
thank you jeff okay thank you uh
is that you fine do you have any more
questions counselor
no that's just all right thanks okay
then um oh mr bellfield do you have any
questions
for the applicant yes please um
i'd just like to ask uh mr
dumblio um if he could confirm how many
covers
uh would be um provided in the new beer
garden area
i think david and paul best to answer
that i think they said
you'd be able to create anything that
says 25 tables is that correct
yeah 25 tables 25 tables
just give me one second
give an answer when you're on site i
think it was about 104 was it or 106
includes the
i hear anything
[Music]
i think i think that also included the
area at the front as well didn't it
all right i was i was just wondering in
in respect to the new
area how many customers could be
accommodated in that new area
okay it would be
twenty
eighty eighty
seated seated customers right okay
um and uh could you
um clarify to the panel and
how close the new bar server will be to
the residential boundary
um i don't have access to the maps that
you've got um it would be
there's like a little cut out on the map
by the side it's as close to the main
building of the pub as we can get it
and it is it would border the red line
that you have
placed on your map right
so that would also sort of back on to
the um
the fenced area at the back so would you
agree it's
possibly less than five meters
the front actual front of the bar survey
would
there is a substantial gap to the
defenses
run there then there is some grass fir a
little bit of a grass verge and it sits
in the old car park spaces
so the front of the server is probably
five
five six meters away from the fence
and um how is the server going to be
powered
um from electricity from inside the
electric feed put into it there'll be no
generators used okay
what what products will you be selling
from the server
we'll be selling spirits wines
soft drinks these coffees
and we've got to do ice creams
and we have looked at drafts so
we'd have to discuss that with star pubs
with that it's possible to do that
um it's not always possible
and that would be we'd have to discuss
the logistics of that with starbucks
and uh would you be looking to serve
like killed bottles perhaps
that would be yeah there would be some
there will be a fridge in there for
two bottles okay
um aside from the server um
what other sale of alcohol activities
would you be planning
in that new beer garden area
well in terms of what
well my understanding is that the air
license
you want to license the entire
new beer garden area so
you've confirmed that you want to say uh
have the server for the sale of alcohol
but i was just wondering where else in
that area would the sale of alcohol
occur and what would that look like um
they're not proposing to sell outcome
anywhere else apart from the bar server
apart from the bar server right it's
okay
um
in terms of um
the resident's complaints um
would you um agree that um i
contacted the pub manager to advise of
complaints and to have a chat with him
about
what is how how the
external area was being operated
if you'd received any complaints we
would really need to hear about them yes
yeah what they're saying is
are you aware that i spoke i spoke to
you
your pub manager i think it was his name
dave perhaps
i don't know sorry excuse me matt yes
um i spoke to matt prior to speaking to
yourselves about complaints
did matt contact you about the matter
not aware of yourself contacting prior
to your visit
i'm aware of one of the licensing
officers attending site for
to check on that area for noise yeah
and he came back with no issues and sent
matt an email confirming the saying
right i contacted matt a second time
once i've
done the monitoring and he uh
preferred than that to
we have a system in place where by at
the end of every day we receive an email
from the
whichever managers it could be due to
manager general manager
and they would detail any issues that
had occurred during the day
any problem customers any issues with
any technology etc so we receive an
email from matt every single day
with um a full report of what's happened
during the day
right we had a conversation um
i think was it before the bank holiday
weekend maybe um
paul um to discuss the complaints and
my concerns and that's when we arranged
to meet i think the following week
is that is that your understanding of is
that your recollection of
events right okay you were raising some
concerns at the time and i said it would
be better for you to come to sites
yeah and see from self rather just
that's right yeah and we had that
meeting
and uh we did we discussed the
complaints and um possible
uh solutions to those complaints
um so i just wanted to ask
um mr dumb leo if he could confirm
in terms of me requests in the um
representation what we are
not in agreement with
um in terms of the agreement
we want the outside bar slavery um
and we want the area to be used for for
customers to to
consume food and drinks until 9pm not
sure
what the question relates to i don't
know is this part of your submission
no i was just wondering it was i just
thought it'd be useful just to clarify
the areas where
we seem to not be in agreement
yeah it's around the use of the outside
world we've agreed with the bifold
thought
plays when live or recorded except for
background music
uh we've agreed for the 9pm um
so it's the like i said we're not
proposing to have a celebrator anywhere
else they're not proposing to have music
or films or tv in that area um
so it is the outside bar survey
okay that's it no more questions thank
you chet
okay okay mr bellfield can i turn to the
member of the public
yeah can i just that's a quick question
folly just
hang on to the member of the public and
counsel the book yeah
thank you chad it's just a quick one um
can you just tell me what the imperative
is to have the bar where it is you know
as close as it's been indicated you know
not of being a bit further on away from
the fence
it's it's the most natural place for it
to be
there is a tree behind it as well which
shields it from the neighboring property
it would also provide additional
protection in terms of
noise because everything would be going
from the front
and in terms of um drainage
and any electrical connections it's it's
situated so close to the end of all the
pub
and
it's just it's it's the most natural
place for it to be and operationally
it creates its own sound barrier because
it's there in in front of
the the space is already there anyway so
there's a five meter gap
roughly between the front of that kiosk
and the uh residence fence
all right i'll turn to the member of the
public now and i apologize for your
weight it's been it's obviously a
bit of a long drawn-out process yes yes
it's okay
as long as i've got as long as he have
that's all i'm asking
well just questions i mean you'll get a
chance to put your representation but
it's just questions of the applicant
about
about his application i haven't got any
questions
all right well you'll get a chance to
actually give your presentation
you know be able to do it in in an order
in an order of uh
of about you know the proceedings
so you will get it this is just
questions of the applicant so
you haven't got any questions no
right no further questions oh sorry
um yes i suppose i have them really
um uh is it my turn to talk
yeah are you happy name hello are you
happy to give your name or your first
name oh
oh yes of course i thought you knew it
totally killed off
say
my house that is um suffering the most
with um with all the noise from the fox
and it's um been from march
this year uh last year it the the
this um beer garden was not in operation
and live literally next door so i see
out
out of the window or you know every day
so
there was no beer garden there it's
happened off
all from march um can i just ask them
um because we're on the questions um
they have been contacted because of the
noise
um and everything i say is true
and i can prove because of the noise the
pub has been
contacted twice um
because um i my health has been affected
with chest pains um
uh i've nearly had them a meltdown
and the nhs contacted the pub
twice and they they haven't moved any of
the tables
away from my property or reduced the
noise
so i can can i ask them why they haven't
um why why didn't they do that yes sir
they they they have been contacted um
by me over the phone i've passed
messages on because they said that they
haven't been contacted and there hasn't
been complaints
there have i've run the pub a numerous
times
tom my neighbor has rang the pub a
numerous times
um and they have done
nothing about reducing
the noise the noise has been
horrendous my home have
duvets over the windows
i can't use that area in my house
i have had to leave my home because
every room
i can hear the noise
do you want to talk about them answer
that question
that you've done carried away you're
gonna not you'll get a chance later on
to make your own representation
and in terms of uh contact from the nhs
we've we've never had contacts from the
nhs
um in respect of miss killed off also
just to clarify
the area was in use from the 4th of july
2020
until such time as the second um
lockdown came into place
and also she references uh march 2021
the area wasn't in use in march 2021 as
we were all closed
and it not
the available had been rounded in my
house
and uh they said to me we cut shall we
go and
have a word with the fox and i said
please
do so they have been round to you then
there was an
ambulance outside the fox car park
and was having a word there it can all
be proven that you only need to ring up
the uh the nhs so i don't know why you
you're
actually denying that um and
i have had chest pains you have been
informed that it is
affecting my health that this noise so
um i have no confidence at all that um
you are going to run this um outside
beer garden
uh right by me because you haven't done
um you have been contacted
the uh the nhs have um and it's it's
only a matter of
i've got two slips that the the um
i had to bring
they had to come out to my house twice
because um i've been that
um i was close to a heart attack
they had to come out to me um
then so i've i can prove all this so i
don't know why you're bothering saying
not so you said to to the committee
in your speech that um
that everything that goes goes on
is emailed every day to to the main
people
well so what's gone wrong there then so
you should have
used it there's something the management
didn't come if they haven't contacted
you over such a serious
issue like that then i think it's very
worrying
i really do just give them a chance to
answer that and then
yes personally certainly yeah
if i may and i appreciate the resident's
concerns or or what the resident is
saying but
if my client hasn't got any evidence of
these complaints or all
from the nhs then then they they haven't
they haven't got
it um and to me this is new evidence
which
which we we haven't seen um
and i suppose that's all i can say on
the point really
yes okay but the thing is what i'm
getting at
if you haven't received that evidence
then why not because the pope or the pub
manager
received that so that should have
immediately gone to you because it's
very very important
that um that obviously
um if you wanted to have done something
they
i don't understand why you didn't
receive um
so if you didn't receive uh the um the
complaint
then why not so something's not running
right
for for you to have not received the
complaints because it definitely
happened
and it happened twice not once twice
okay i think we're gonna have to move on
because obviously they're saying they
haven't received it and we
you know we're just speculating about
what happened we hear what you say and
we're sorry
about your health issues obviously yeah
if i may just interject as well
sorry we we have been no evidence of
this might have pointless but
there's been no evidence submitted by
this resident of
these complaints being made there's no
evidence of an nhs slip there's no
evidence of this complaint actually
being sent to the premises
there's nothing here but there seems to
be
obviously some uh disagreement or
with you know a misunderstanding of
whether
it was received or not but i think we're
gonna have to move on because we
we're gonna go around interject please
chair
um miss kilduck is raising matters now
that we're not in her original
representation
um so under the regulations you you can
only consider
things that she brought up in our
original representation so the
issue about the nhs is not to be taken
into account
okay fair point can i just bring in then
the environmental health office can i
can i ask them to make their
representation
about the uh about the application thank
you
and peter bellfield environmental health
officer for pollution
housing team of traffic council um as
we've heard the
application is for a number of changes
to the premises
license however my objection relates to
the proposal to
amend the licensing plan which
accomplish the
accompanies the application and to
permit the sale of alcohol
from an external bar server and from a
new beer garden area on a redundant car
park
and as we've heard the use of the car
park this year commenced in
on the 12th of april on easing of the
national
lockdown restrictions that permitted
hospitality venues to reopen
and notably the beer garden had been
covered by a marquee like structure
which was open around the sides
um i understand the bay garden was also
operated for a time last year
and i can confirm that i did receive a
complaint
uh in respective noise although um
i followed up that complaint but i
didn't receive any reply so no further
action was taken
however this year uh two residents have
complained of excessive noise from
talking laughter and shouting from the
marquee
which had been erected directly adjacent
to their
gardens and the use is subject to an
ongoing planning application and my
initial advice in response to this
application was to
seize the operation of the new beer guys
in at 9 pm in line with the
institute of acoustics guidelines and
the control of noise from pubs and clubs
and when i subsequently discussed
the um uh the the complaints with the
pub manager matt um
he conferred to me that they were
adhering to this curfew as agreed
uh nonetheless complaints continued to
be received
with one resident stating that the pub
was open all day and when the
weather was warm uh the noise was there
all day and
something had to be done and the
resident's health was being affected and
not
not been able to use the garden or to
open the windows as they normally would
have been
doing in the warm weather and that the
noise travels
inside their house and to investigate
residents allegations of nuisance they
installed noise monitoring equipment
into the closest residence property on
the 7th of may this year
the monitoring equipment is and
grade a equipment it measures decibel
levels every second
and it allows the complainant to make
audio recordings by pressing a hand
switch
the equipment was set up in the rear
ground floor living
room which included a side door that was
kept open for ventilation
whilst i was visiting and noted that the
resident's fence
the boundary fence was fairly
dilapidated and um
of a slatted timber construction that
had many gaps and holes uh that i
thought
could be letting in quite a significant
amount of noise through
and i i reviewed the collected monitored
evidence and noted that the audio
recordings
clearly demonstrated the receipts of
intrusive noise
from the hub of the customers voices
shouts
and laughter throughout the late
afternoon and evening
subjectively the beer gown has sounded
to be
quite popular especially during the
evening
with the sound of various different
conversations
merging into loud laughter merging
together with loud laughter and raised
voices frequently
being audible above the hubbub um in the
residence property
after 8 p.m the noise level of lively
conversation
was found to range between 47 and 50
decibels with maximum levels of around
55 or more
drawing the loudest shouts and laughter
um
during a background recording taken
whilst the equipment was being set up
for comparative purposes with
little activity in the bay garden noise
levels range between
38 to 41 decibels so you can see the
clear difference which i would say is
substantially
in acoustic terms and it can be nice to
be
intrusive in nature and have the
potential to cause a clear nuisance
impact
even with the 9 pm curfew being adhered
to
the most troublesome part of the noise i
found was the frequent rays voices
shouts and loud laughter which would be
particularly annoying to listen to
on a regular basis and it's important to
know that the
affected residents are not likely to
have been subject to this
level and type of noise in any
significant quantities whilst the area
is being used as a
car park and while the these properties
benefit
from a good degree of screening and
distance separation to the existing
outside seats around the pub in addition
the use of the beer garden the new beer
garden is likely to be most
popular during the weekend and periods
of good weather when residents
would want to use and enjoy their
amenities spaces
during the day and evening and as we've
heard i subsequently
met with the applicants and the
breweries representative to discuss
whether any mitigation and controls
could be agreed
um and as we've heard it is clarified
that
the size of the new bay garden was quite
substantial and could accommodate over
100 seated guests
and the intention was to do this
irrespective of coal with
restrictions they had plans to do this
before covered
and i also found that a number of
benches have been positioned outside of
the marquee
and very close to the residence fence
and um
i considered that these ought to be
removed because it was so close to the
residence fence
uh and i felt that these particularly
were
quite a high risk in terms of noise
impact and
i noticed whilst i was um converting
underneath the marquee that the quality
of the noise was
quite reverberant and i considered that
the marking was
likely to be letting the noise build up
inside and
increasing the noise breakout from the
sides towards residents
and the closest residential building uh
directly to north is only around 10
meters from the edge of the marquis
cover
and we discussed the need for an
acoustic fence of sufficient height and
mass
to be installed along the residential
boundary to protect
the external immunity spaces of those
properties
for information the effect of a barrier
would
um if partial screening is achieved it
results in a reduction of five decibels
and if full screening is achieved
um then this would go up to 10 decibels
so i expect a two meter barrier
of sufficiently dense materials to act
as an acoustic barrier so that's 10
meters
10 kilograms per meter squared
superficial mass
and i estimate this will achieve a
reduction of about seven decibels to the
external areas
um the proposed position of the bar
kiosk as we heard would only be about
five meters away from residential
property which i
feel is too close and even with a two
meter
acoustic barrier being installed
residents will still be able to
overlook the barrier from habitable
rooms
of the first floor um at close range
and i mentioned that i couldn't support
the inclusion of the kiosk because it
encouraged customers to
approach and congregate the around the
the area uh so close to residents
and there could be also additional
impact from the activities of staff
and bottles being discarded into bins
and so i really was against the idea of
having this server in that location
um just because it was bringing the um
the activity too close to the residence
with no real
uh options for fully mitigating against
the impacts um
i was also averse to anything that would
intensify the use of the
whole beer garden as a whole the new
beer garden as a whole by encouraging
customers
to take up those seats where they could
be more sensitively accommodated within
the external
within the existing bird garden
provision
and as we've heard i've got concerns
about congregations of
standing groups of customers and
bbqs generators um
eating equipment screening of tv films
or sport
provision of live and recorded musical
entertainment
i wouldn't want this happening in that
new area because the
way that could intensify the use of the
area and increase noise impact
as as we've heard discuss the
possibility of noise breakout from
inside the premises the actual pub
itself
and we have agreed that um
this could be addressed by a condition
requiring the bi-fold doors to be kept
closed from 9 p.m
so that simplifies the condition that i
put in my original representation which
referred to whilst
entertainment was underway and that can
be simplified to
basically refer to a 9 pm
at which the bifold doors need to be
closed
and i have an email from the applicant
subsequent to that meeting to confirm
that they would operate a curfew to 9 pm
as i mentioned the double uh the um
rifle doors will be closed at nine as
well uh
they have double gates out external
gates to the
um external area which
they will close to prevent customers
accessing after nine
and direct they also confirmed that they
were direct signs to advise patrons of
the operating times of the beer garden
and the restrictions um and that no
televisions
no sports no live music no barbecues
generators heating equipment will be
used
and that the area will be used as a
seating area in line with its current
use
and it was it was also mentioned in the
email that the
uh applicant would be agreeable to not
serving alcohol from the server and just
keeping it to sell ice creams and for
christmas attractions
um but they'd seek to license the car
park to carry on with their current
operations
and so obviously you know i now know
that
the intention is to actually serve
alcohol from that
server and to license the whole area
i'd like to mention that the current
premises license provides for off sales
i.e the sale of alcohol for consumption
off the license premises which should
permit
table service of alcohol from beer
alcohol purchased um and brought
from inside the pub out to the tables
and however i would be adverse to
actually selling alcohol within that
area uh because it
as i say it does over it's intensified
each of the
area and it encourages customers to
occupy that area in preference to
uh more sensitively uh positioned um
external
seats and so i
would want to see a restriction on the
boundary of the licensed area to
ensure that licensable activities don't
take place close to the residential
boundary
and i would refer to the uh
representation of the 26th of may
where included a plant with a red line
above which
uh i didn't want customers to be able to
use
um because i thought that would be going
too close to the boundary
and in all really i consider the only
reasonable use of that area because it
is so sensitive
more sensitive than the other areas
would be to as an ancillary seating area
for
when there is covered restrictions and
people can't be accommodated normally
and when the pub is particularly busy um
just touching on the marquee it's likely
that the marquee is enhancing the use of
that area because
if you're a smoker you know the outside
areas of the marquee
are open you could sit under there and
um
drink and smoke and also be protected
from the elements
and so i i do feel as though it
encourages people to occupy that area
against taking other seats
um so i wouldn't request
markings and restricted and i
do not you know wouldn't encourage the
use of market on that area
um in addition um
my representation uh contains requests
um to protect the residents from the
possibility of nuisance impact
and i would not advise um that they the
panel to grant
um a premises license a varied premises
license
uh which permits the sale of alcohol
from the bar server
or from uh fro from anywhere within the
um new
um external areas of the west of the
port
um due to the possibility of
like i say people occupying that area
and preface
to other areas if you if you could buy
and have alcohol um
provided for you without ever having to
go inside the pub
then you know you may just wish to
see the car park as the pub for you
really so
it's i feel it's it's going too far
really and it's encouraging people
to be there as as in instead of actually
going to the pub
or to the existing seating areas and
i also mentioned that um the
area to the north of the red line shown
in the map should not be used for
for customer um customers to occupy
because this could be too close to
residents
and i would also request that
the process license does refer to the
um the acoustic barrier that i've
requested
because i do think it is important and
um
it it's clearly needed um
to protect the external areas of those
residential properties
and so i would request that it is
made as a condition of the um an early
granted
license and
just moving on operationally there are a
number of conditions
three conditions that i feel would be
necessary to control
operational impacts from the use of the
garden and
the first one being that the outside
seating area positioned on the farmer
car parts of the western pub building
shall not be
used by customers outside the hours of
1100
and 2100 on any day customers shall not
be
allowed to remove glasses or bottles
from premises and take them to the
this area except between these hours the
double gates leading
from the front their gunners shall be
kept close outside the hours of
11 and 20 100 on any day
signs indicating the restrictions of you
shall be placed in the permit
area adjacent to the entrance and exit
of the area and retain you know
retained at all times thereafter and the
second condition
is that the area permitted for use as an
external seating area shall not be used
for the following activities at any time
the erection of a marquee or cover into
the seating area
congregations or groups of standing
customers
the preparation of or cooking of hot
food the operation
of petrol or diesel driven electricity
generating equipment for less for
emergency purposes
the operation of exterior heating
equipment the screening of tv films or
sports
on the provision of live or recorded
musical entertainment
and lastly the condition requiring
except for emergency access the approved
bi-fold doors
leading to the side garden area
following main clothes after 2 100 hours
until the end of the day's
business and that that's
all i have to say uh thank you very much
chair
and thank you mr bellfield can i just
ask you you said you received
uh quite a few complaints could you
just of this nature could could you just
say how many and over what
roughly how many perhaps or exactly how
many i know yeah
sorry i am i i received um one complaint
last year
that's um i followed up but i didn't
receive a reply so
didn't follow it up any further i
received two complaints
this year after the um
beer garden was opened on the it was the
12th of
april two two residential complaints
okay thank you i'll just ask my fellow
councillors if you have any questions
for you
council the book councillor thomas now
no thank you chad
no further question for me there thank
you can i just ask the applicant
if they have any questions for mr
bellfield please
mr domino no questions chair
thank you okay um
so miss kaldoff do you have any
questions for
me no no
thank you i think um no right
okay well in that case it's your turn to
make your representation
of your own right
okay
i'm just looking at the paperwork that
i've
wrote out i'm sorry i can't uh obviously
a lot has been said here
um i am the main thing is um
that i wouldn't be here um i've been
drinking in the pub
um before um you know
where a few years back and i never
wanted to do this but i've had no choice
the noise has just been too much um
nobody nobody could live um
with with this noise um
and uh i just i just need
something done um i can't live in my
house any longer if nothing is done
that's the definite
um there there's
also i mean going back this has been
going on
i think from march and um i get um
kids um kicking
footballs at the fence
so it's an additional noise from
thump and then the balls go over then
the kids are
climbing um at the side
of can i just stop that's not relation
to the pub
what i'm saying is nothing's there the
manager does nothing about
it he's done nothing he says what i'm
saying is is nothing i don't know why
nothing has been done
sooner about um the situation with the
noise when they know
they've been told about it um
so you know i don't know why they've let
me suffer
i don't get that at all um
and the management do not have all i've
done is been
watching outside and the management does
not go out to rowdy
people and bars enough at the tables and
asks them
to move or to be quieter nothing
they don't it just seems to be out of
control they just do what they want
but they just have them there's been no
uh concern at all showed
by the fox pub for me
and tom since march over the noise
um just let me look at my notes
you okay uh yes i'm sorry i'm
i'll just um i'm getting a bit shaky but
i'm just going through my notes i think
a lot has been said
really um and um
you know i just basically want this
noise to stop
um because i will have to leave my
property
um because if it doesn't
it's as simple as that really um
you know and the amount of people
uh you know that's it the 90 people
outside them in this
beer garden and and i'm hearing them
laughing and joking
um and you know i can't do anything in
my house i'd have to leave my house
and sit in the car down the road a few
times i've had to do that because of
this noise
um i just don't know why it's come to
this why they didn't do anything about
it
um i would never have done that to any
of neighbours
so i'm just very worried really to be
honest because
uh i don't have any confidence that this
is going to change
the noise will um you know it it hasn't
changed so far
and they have been informed
so i just don't know um what to say uh i
i i
appreciate you um hearing me but um
i just i just want the noise to stop and
i've i've been here in the property for
15 years and there's
never been a problem there's always you
know people passing by and getting in
the cars
and you accept that sort of noise but
the noise that i've had to
endure for um people sitting there all
day
i literally can't be in my house
i can't you know i'm already looking at
um
other properties because i just can't be
here if it carries on i just can't
all right i don't know what else to say
it's uh peter said a lot really
um but um you know
and it is that the decibels of noise is
too much
and the amount of tables that they put
right at my property
it's right next to it they did not move
uh next door so
um across the road you mean on
oh no no i thought you just
no no i'm not being funny here
we didn't have your name or address
that's because it's annoying
i did i did give them my uh address
so i i don't know why you haven't looked
at the map it's anonymized for
for obvious reasons but you okay so you
live next door to the pub
i live next door but i get the full
blast of all those those benches
of of noise it's it's literally
just um and then tom next door to me
he gets a full blast there's another
issue
um the the the kitchen fans
and toms ran them up um
tom couldn't be here because he's just
started a new job
and um he um he's under a lot of
pressure with that otherwise he'd have
been here
he's been reporting to peter over the
noise as well
and he works from home and he's um
stressed as well over over the noise and
the fans from the kitchen pub go on
all through the night um
tom's asked them to um you know to
shut them up
i'm not saying this this doesn't take
place but you because you didn't put it
in your representation
we can't consider it because you didn't
include it in your letter you can only
consider what
your objection what you put in the
letter look this is something else you'd
have to take it up
separately to this to this hearing
really
is there anything else without repeating
what you've already said that you need
yes i know what you're saying but all i
all i'm getting at
is that they're not running the pub
um in uh consideration to the neighbors
that's my point um
you know there's there's been no
uh consideration to the immediate
neighbors since
march um so i i don't
understand why they're saying that
they're going to change this and change
that well there hasn't been any
consideration for us
at all okay so thanks for that
can i just ask the other members of the
council if they have any questions for
you
no thank you no thank you chad
no okay um can i ask the the applicant
if
he has any questions for the resident
please questions thank you
no can i have mr bellfield do you have
any questions for the rest of the chair
i don't thank you
okay i think then that can that
concludes all the
submissions um so i think what what
we'll do now is
is we'll have a recess um
the panel and the legal officer will uh
pop into a to a room electronically
uh to make a decision and then then
we'll come back
and deliver this the decision to the
meeting
opportunity to sort the two minutes oh
sorry
did i not do that i do beg your pardon
yeah you want to sum up yeah sorry i
should have done that
yes please too yeah
well i think because of the applicant we
go last chair i think that's the right
order yeah just keep
keeping up with the process
please do yeah
[Music]
hello sorry is it you gave it to mr
bellfield and the resident first and
then we'll go
at the end of the applicant to sum up i
think that's the correct
method i think that's what you said at
the start okay
mr bellfield would you like to sum up um
yes uh thank you chair um i'd just
like to uh reiterate that um
i do think valid complaints have been
made
and i've put monitoring equipment
in i've detected a
quite significant increase in noise
levels uh the noise
is intrusive it's not pleasant to listen
to
you know in in other successive days
um i've been trying to work with the pub
and i appreciate that we've made some
progress
in how the um how the bayer garden is to
be operated
and what constraints need to be applied
but i
feel that the application does ask
too much of that area considering how
sensitive it is
um and i think putting the bar
server so close to residents
is is not good for them um
really that area needs to be kept clear
to keep a buffer between customers
and the residents and
they they want to enjoy their external
areas as well they need to be protected
uh there does need to be a barrier there
and i
don't see the need to um
license the whole area to set sell
alcohol
and they have enough license where
customers can uh enjoy
consuming drinks there and i think the
area of the bay garden needs to be
clearly marked so it doesn't encroach
close to the residents and and and
control that's per the
um the conditions but um the server
really is is
is too much i think and it allows people
to congregate
so close in lively spirits so i i
wouldn't recommend that
um it is uh part of the license
thank you jeff thank you mr bellfield um
i can ask the member of the public miss
kildoff
yes hello hello would you just like to
sum up your
um representation please
right yes yes i'm sorry i've i've just
don't use fancy words i'm not used to
meeting things and stuff
i i've just basically um i'm just trying
to live
in my house and um i get on with my life
and the noise i can't live
with in this house any longer
um and i feel that they've done nothing
about it at all um i have
asked them um a few times and they
haven't changed
anything they have i don't know why but
they haven't moved
any tables away from the barrier
you know i don't know how anybody can
operate like that
it's just to me that shows a lack of
respect
after i've made a complaint to them and
they haven't even
moved any tables all the tables are just
spread out
um and the right next to my um
fence which is just totally
um it's it's it's not very good
management
as far as i'm concerned i've run my own
business
for 24 years and had dogs barking
and had to always consider the neighbors
and you never received any complaints
from
dogs barking because of me
causing it and that just goes to show
you
that it can be done um
but and all the people that all the the
community here
they've spoke with them all recently and
they never had
any problem and neither did the council
receive any complaints through dogs
barking so um and uh
you know i don't understand why they
they haven't even moved any tables away
or done anything they haven't been out
on that when it's been busy and all i've
done
since march is look over at the beer
garden and no one has
has kept as us noise to be kept to a
minimum
after i've told them that it's really
really bad at my house
and in actual fact matt said to me once
over the fence tony what do you expect
you live next door to a pub that was
what he said to me
what do you expect
now i'm not telling lies i just want the
noise
to stop and i want to just carry on with
and i appreciate they've got to run a
business
but as far as i'm concerned they the
lack of management
that they've showed they should have
reduced the tables immediately
if as soon as they got one complaint and
moved some to the front of the date pub
straight away they should have done that
and they've done nothing and that's why
i am here today other than that we it
shouldn't have got like this
she really shouldn't have right thank
you very much for listening to me
okay miss miss kilda thank you very much
for you
for your importance um okay mr dom leo
apologies for that would you like to sum
up the uh the application please
no no problem at all thank you i won't
take up too much time
as i alluded too early in my submission
your decision needs to be
evidence-based and from hearing from
he said there was one complaint last
year when the area was in huge sorry
alleged complaint this wasn't it was
followed up but the
complaint didn't do anything about it
and there's been two complaints
this year again alleged there's no
evidence
from those times or when the area has
been in use
um that has caused an issue and
undermined the
license there's no evidence of
complaints from um the resident
unfortunately of of complaints there's
no evidence of photos
showing the area usually causing an
issue
um we have agreed with peter for the
area not to use that tonight um
peter wants the area to not view before
11am but i don't see
what the issue would be if i wanted to
sit out there and have a coffee
um at nine o'clock in the morning i
don't see what the issue would be
we've agreed nine o'clock for the area
we've agreed
for signs to be erected we've agreed
that
for staff to monitor the area uh we've
also agreed for the bi-fold doors to be
closed
when the outside seating area um when
the buildings remain closed at all times
when live and recorded music included
from a dj
not background music or taking place
yeah
and i understand that's now changed
actually from what peter is asking for
which i wasn't aware of we've agreed to
the condition on page 48 of the agenda
account
as i said in my submission david and
paul they have invested like i said a
considerable amount of time and effort
and money
into running these premises there is not
a history of
complaints of the other external areas
so i say you should have full confidence
that they will trade this external area
as they have done for the premises peter
is happy
with the area to be used until nine pm
um it's because he doesn't want the
outside bar survey there to be used but
as i've said i don't see
how the area is going to be used more
because of our service there and any of
them
our survey can't be used after 9pm we
have included conditions which are
appropriate and
fortunate and as i said before if there
are issues in the future
then the residents do have the power to
call a review
peter can issue a review the environment
1990s
use a noise abatement notice and also if
you're speaking with david
and paul they are um they are willing to
provide
the lady the resident with a contact
number for them so if there are any
issues then
they can contact this number um
but we are not aware of any complaints
being made it has to be everyday based
counselors and i would ask you to grant
it
with the additional condition if you
have agreed as it is before you thank
you
anyway there's anything uh david or paul
want to add on to
that or andrew
oh we're fine thank you i'm from me
thank you
okay thank you very much um
we'll go into a breakout room now with
the with the legal officer and then
we'll
return in a few minutes with our verdict
okay thank you for your contributions
everyone thank you
thank you thank you okay we're recording
again
okay thank you natalie okay we've come
to a decision about the
variation of the license and we're going
to allow the variation in part
only so of the
four of the four aspects of the
no problem with that item three
the non-standard timings for licensable
activities
for new year's eve and new year's day
we're gonna
going to allow that till to one o'clock
item four uh we're not happy with the
2200 hours so we're gonna we're gonna
uh amend the wording as you as you
suggested but keeping it
twenty one hundred hours so it will read
children under the age of 16 must be
accompanied by an adult at all times
and must be off the premises by 2 100
hours
unless on new year's eve when they will
committed to remain
unaccompanied by until
close so
on point two um
we're amending the outside area to
drawing 2057
301 we're going to allow that but with
the following
condition
so condition one the outside the outdoor
seating area positioned on the former
car park to the west of the pub
shall not be used by customers after the
hours of 2100
we're going to remove the um the
starting time and we're just going to
say after the hours of 2100 on any day
until close of business customers shall
not be allowed to remove glasses or
bottles from the premises
and take them to this area except
between these hours
or before this that hour prior to the
use of the area commencing
details of a suitable restriction to
prevent customers accessing this area
shall be submitted to the licensing
authority
for approval and the improved
restrictions
shall be kept in place before the hour
before the hour 2100 hours on any day
prior to the use of the area commencing
signs indicating
the restrictions of the youth
shall be placed in a prominent position
engaged into the entrance
and exit of the of the area and retained
at all times thereafter now condition
two the outdoor seating area positioned
on the former car park to the west of
the pub building
shall not be used for the following
activities at any time
the sale of alcoholic drinks erection of
a marquee or covering to the seating
area
congregations with standing groups of
customers
any screenings of tv films or sports
and the provisions of live or recorded
musical entertainment
condition three except for the emergency
egress
the bipolar doors leading to the outdoor
seating area
positioned on the former car park to the
west of the pub building
shall remain closed at all times when
any performances of live music
including from a dk but with
accepting background pre-recorded music
are taking place within the area
annotated as a dining area
stroke function room to the supporting
drawing rep
2057-301
we considered the request for an
acoustic barrier
but we felt that this is a matter for
planning
and environmental help if they wish to
pursue this would have to pursue it
alongside the planning application
and as for the the red line
beyond where the customers are
encroaching the uh
in the seating area outside we don't
think that this
would be enforceable and so we're not
going to adopt that
as a condition and
[Music]
we believe that the noise levels from
one from 106
covers would be too much for the
residents to stop
her bearing in mind neighbours are
particularly close
to the the seating area
we would urge the landlord to give the
number to
ms um to report any problems from the
outside area
and any ongoing problems should it
should be
could be reported to the licensing
licensing department um
so basically you know as i said the
reasons are due to the close proximity
of residence and potential impact
of the survey an associated absence
potential impact for public nuisance
under other residents
so i know it's not what the advocate
wanted to hear that you know
because of the close proximity to the
name
cheat by joel with the drinking area
and the issues that have been caused in
the past
that we feel that only allow it within
these conditions
obviously you will be written to with
the verdicts of the panel
and you will have the right of appeal
carer for may then just to clarify you
you've granted the
use of the outside air until nine but
not the outside bar
yes we're not allowing the outside bar
at all
right thank you
okay um can i i think that
concludes the meeting i'd like to thank
everybody for their participation and
their contributions for the meeting
um and like i say the third it will be
reported to the applicant who will have
the right of appeal
i suspect he might um and with that
you should all be able to catch the
second half of the england match
so i'll thank everybody for their
contribution
and uh i'll close the meeting and say
good night
okay many thanks
[Music]